so get 15 grams of protein in if your
train strength training and if you're
adding in a little bit of cardio at any
point you want to add 10 or 15 grams of
carbohydrate we say about 30 30. yeah
all up you're looking at maybe 150
calories total before you're doing a
strength and and cardiovascular type
workout otherwise it's around 100
calories from protein
yeah that's more than 15 grams though
right I mean so like 20 grams ish yeah
five yeah so they say 90 but who does 90
calories you're like what's 90. we'll
just round it up yeah what's the role of
fat because you know fat you know fat
coffee or Bulletproof Coffee kind of
thing has been such a craze is fat uh
detrimental or is it just not helpful
and so if you're looking from a training
perspective it takes a really long time
to get out of your stomach and
intestines so it doesn't really fuel you
in any scope of the matter
the thing with Bulletproof Coffee and
all the things that they're like here's
your MCTS and your coffee it's for
satiation it's to help with that okay
let's get that cognitive focus and hold
that caffeine because it extends the
half-life of caffeine it also clears out
your blood sugar so you feel like you're
focused but really you're just on the
edge of being hypoglycemic and so it's
about the satiation and extending the
half-life of the caffeine yeah because
it is satiating it does curb your hunger
when I again like I said I did a lot of
fasting and I mean I was like 24 36 18
24 you know like doing like big fasts
and or what feels like big fast because
I don't like to be hungry
um it I mean coffee with a little bit of
fat or like a you know Nut Butter like a
like a cup like a fat cut fat bomb kind
of thing like that stuff would be like I
mean you could survive on 200 calories a
day or 300 just like because you've kept
enough fat in you to to say shape but
that makes sense with the caffeine to it
it extends that life okay just using me
as an example for morning workout people
what about afterwards with a refeed
timing like what kind of macros are more
important after specifics for strength
training when you are in your
reproductive years it's 30 grams of good
quality protein High leucine containing
protein when we start to hit light
perimenopause and menopause it's 40
grams because we have more anabolic
resistance so if we want to make the
strength training work for us we also
had to have a higher amount of
circulating amino acids post-exercise
and we see that it's a 30 to 45 minute
window after strength training to really
get that in for women for men it's a
different story because you see oh it's
not that important for the nutrient
timing for men but again it's because
the way that they come back down to
Baseline is different from women they
can hold off having
um food for up to two to three hours
before they really take a hit but for
women it's such a short window because
we come back down to Baseline so quickly
and then should it be more does the
carbohydrate or fat matter with fueling
after a workout for strength training
not so much but if we're looking at a
cardiovascular standpoint we look to get
about one gram of carbohydrate with that
30 grams of protein so one gram per
kilogram so what is that trying to
convert my head from metric to Imperial
so if it's one gram per kilo should be
half a gram per pound of carbohydrate
with your 30 grams of protein what about
out muscle synthesis is it called muscle
synthesis or protein synthesis when you
kind of have a certain amount of protein
every so often in the day there's like a
mechanism there what what is that yeah
so that's your muscle protein synthesis
or your mtor we look at regular
distribution throughout the day to keep
a certain amount of amino acids
circulating so that you're getting a
feedback that okay we're going to turn
it off then we're going to turn it on
then we're going to turn it off and then
we're going to turn it on I think this
is also where that conversation of well
you can't have more than 25 grams of
protein because it's not absorbed it
comes from which is not true we see that
there's a certain amount that will turn
on the mtor and anything above that
isn't that beneficial for muscle protein
synthesis okay but it is beneficial for
other things in the body like
neurotransmitter Health gut health where
other things are using amino acids so
when we're talking about like that 30
gram hit for women it's not that the
extra five grams isn't going to be
absorbed or it's going to be he turned
into fat that's complete BS we look at
it as like we need that extra leucine
that's coming from those 30 grams to
really tip over the amount of leucine
that's in the muscle to keep that mtor
working for women and the extra
essential amino acids that are
circulating is going to go for
neurotransmitter health or some of the
other aspects like within the gut or
nervous system now for men it's that 20
grams because that's all they need to
tip over that that mtor and yeah if
they're getting a little bit more again
they have more circulating for other
things hmm so and then if you do that
it's like four times a day is that or
what is the what is the magic formula to
activate mtor and what does mtor do
so mtor is
um
it is a protein that actually stimulates
the satellite cell to
develop and so this is where we're
talking about muscle protein synthesis
we're talking about the proteins that
develop into muscle cells got it so it
starts in the brain and feeds forward to
the muscle and so it's a feedback
mechanism we're looking at how to keep
that kind of even throughout the day we
say around 30 grams at each meal so
that's three times and then 15 grams at
each snack and then if you're training
hard then you're going to be altering a
little bit because there's a certain set
amount of protein that you want to get
in a day
that Baseline is about 1.1 grams per
pound especially as we get older and
then you can divide it up so you might
need to have a little bit more at your
meal you might look at having a little
bit more especially post exercise so it
depends on where you are and what you're
doing with your training as well as just
keeping it at regular intervals
throughout the day okay so a little bit
more with around training maybe a little
bit less otherwise and is there a
certain amount of meals in a day because
I feel like that's another that's
another area that's come and gone so
much is like you know lots of little
meals throughout the day to the theory
of just you know omad one meal or two
meals and having long long Windows of
you know time restricted feeding
um
what is what is best for I mean if you
want to cover cover the bases men and
women but definitely for for women in
general like what is what is the right
amount of meals to have in a day
I don't know if it's the right amount of
meals because that's kind of individual
but there's a lot of really cool
interesting research coming out about
your circadian rhythm okay and we know
that women's rhythms are a little bit
longer than men's so this is why we tend
to want to go to bed earlier and get up
earlier because our our circadian is a
little bit different than men's
so if we're looking at how
horizontal Peaks and drops and how our
hormones pulse and drop because it does
throughout the day we have pulses we
know that eating more up to about the
one o'clock period and then starting to
taper down and having a little bit more
of your carbohydrate scope
in the earlier part of the day and more
the protein scope towards the afternoon
is how it works with your body's Rhythm
and then when we get into people who are
like oh I've been doing time restricted
eating and I need to do this and then
it's like well first let's look at that
research has been done on rats has been
done on men and has been on done on
obese sedentary women but if you're
really hard and fast pulled to that rule
then stop eating after dinner and then
eat breakfast so you have a 12 hour
window overnight which is really called
regular eating but then you're also
giving your body a little break with
your circadian rhythm
so the best is that I I mean that's
probably the most common I fasting just
isn't my favorite and
um uh it never has been but I tried and
but what feels logical is somewhere
around that 12 or 13 hours whatever that
circadian sort of more fasting window
um so is that is that something safe
that you can do all the time then yeah
absolutely because if we're looking at
like the big scope for health right we
see all these little Trends where you're
trying to
micromanage your body composition your
micromanaging how you feel but it's not
long term like if you're looking at long
term who can do time restricted or
fasting for you know your 16 hour fast
that kind of stuff right it's not that
sustainable for life so when we pull it
back down to more granular and we're
looking at the way that our body
responds to day and night and we see
that we have this circadian rhythm that
also changes across the seasons with
daylight we can stick to the the pattern
of we our body needs more fuel when we
are awake to help with hormone to help
with cognition to help with Focus so
when we look at scoping that again like
I said carbohydrate up till you know
around the noon one o'clock and then a
little bit more protein not saying no
protein and no carbohydrate just the way
you Scope it and then it's at night time
not eating like because we've gotten out
of the habit of what it means to eat and
sit down and have a meal because you see
people eating in their car you have
people who are eating at dinner at 11
o'clock at night like they're we've lost
kind of not really the quote rules of
eating but we've become so disconnected
of what it means to be nourished and
it's like oh I'm eating because I'm
bored or I'm eating because I'm hungry
or I'm eating because my friend's eating
like we've become so disconnected so if
we think about it from like okay what
does my body need it needs energy now
and I need to sleep well so I'm not
going to eat two hours before bed
because I want a really good
parasympathetic response while I'm
sleeping and then I'm going to wake up
and body's going to need fuel so I'm
going to eat breakfast
that's just a general pattern that
everyone I think has lost in modern day
yeah yeah I yeah I agree and part of it
is so much mixed information absolutely
yeah um so then if we're if if you're if
you're going to hold up to sort of that
12-ish hour window which is probably the
best for gut health and sleep as well
then if you know take for instance me I
leave to go work out at 6 30 in the
morning so I'll want to back that up
from that sort of 15 20 grams of protein
that I have at 6 30 in the morning to 6
30 at night right or just that or does
that little bump in the morning not
really count oh it's looking at fuel for
some training that you're going to be
doing right it's not going to break into
all the health benefits and
parasympathetic response you have so
it's 12 hours or it's 11 hours but
you're just getting a good break between
10 and 12 hours where your body can kind
of rest digest get in to parasympathetic
do the reparation it needs that happens
while you're sleeping consolidate
memories consolidate physical activity
stress all of those things it's just
when you're eating right before bed then
that stays in the system right and you
can't get into the parasympathetic that
you need to have optimal sleep
architecture more about sleep it's more
about the sleep and recovery and
parasympathetic state that your body
needs to get into so that you can
actually properly
um
refuel by sleeping right or you know
recover yep okay okay yeah I understand
let's finish off with some supplements
because I feel like this is another area
that gets again there's just so much
information about it
um you talked about creatine I had
actually never taken creatine until
about a week ago and then I started and
I had I just like it wasn't something
that anyone ever really recommended
highly it wasn't something that and I
feel like women get afraid of it because
I mean even my first instinct I was like
oh this is like is that water weight
like a little bit of like I was like oh
and women get scared of that but then
it's like no the whole point is is that
you put lean muscle lean muscle mass on
and to have more you know or better
resting metabolic rate with the amount
of lean muscle mass you have and you
know even if it doesn't do anything it
goes further than that so creatine has
now been named by The Who as an
essential nutrient for women stop it
yeah oh my God something that scares so
many women is literally really an
essential and from what I've heard that
to get the right amount of creatine to
get the three grams or four or five or
whatever it is that you take you need
like a couple pounds of animal meat yeah
and I'm a vegetarian so I'm already
compromised right wow I know so when we
look at the research in Abby Smith Ryan
out of UNC has done a lot of research on
Creatine not only like in the sports
space but in the General Health space
across a woman's lifespan
so we see that it's essential for
pregnancy as well so when like no
supplements during pregnancy but
creatine is actually super beneficial so
when we look at creatine and what it
does it supports all the fast
bioenergetics in in the body so we're
looking at gut health and we're looking
at the mucosal membrane of our
intestines and for women we degrade it a
lot faster than men so this is why we
have greater incidences of GI distress
we look at brain health and mood and
there have been some really cool
clinical trials looking at SSRI and
creatine versus just SSRI and really
depressive episodes and women who are
adding creatine don't drop into the
significant really severe depressive
episodes and if they do they come out of
it really quickly because creatine is so
important for brain health and women
have 70 to 80 percent of the stores that
men have and then by the nature of not
eating as much or being more aware that
of the in impact of animal protein
they're not eating as much either so
they're really low in creatine
unbelievable so every woman should take
creatine every day for
ever yeah either that or eat a lot more
meat if you like this clip and you want
to hear the whole episode click at the
bottom of your screen